Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg is telling
Harvard graduates to take risks and
create a purpose for today's world
zuckerberg joked about giving the
commencement speech at his old school
more than a decade after he dropped out
i am honored to be here with you today
because let's face it you accomplished
something I never could if I get through
this speech today it'll be the first
time I actually finished something here
at Harvard Facebook has grown to more
than one point nine billion users since
Zuckerberg launched the company from his
dorm room in 2004 Reuters reports the
world's biggest social media company has
signed deals with entertainment sites
like BuzzFeed for its upcoming original
video service Facebook did not comment
on that report CBS News contributor
Nicholas Thompson is editor in chief of
Wired Nick good morning morning room so
Mark Zuckerberg had said in an earnings
call earlier this month I see video as a
mega trend on the same order as mobile
these new deals what does that mean
about Facebook strategy so Facebook has
been committed very significantly to
video for quite a while and initially it
was Facebook live remember it came out
last year and the whole world is gonna
be about live video turns out they
didn't have quite the engagement they
thought but they did have a lot of
engagement with sort of more serious
more scripted more professional videos
and so they are now pushing very hard
into that and they're going to be a lot
more like YouTube with commercial breaks
they say with commercial breaks to make
people money they are trying to be a new
form of TV is it going to be news
entertainment what are we talking about
here well there's the other thing
they're scared about they want they see
the engagement numbers at YouTube they
want that and they want young people
they want they're worried about snapchat
so you look at the demographics the 18
to 24 year olds are using snapchat more
than Facebook so a lot of it is going to
be entertainment aimed at that
demographic everybody seems to be
getting in this YouTube is getting into
this snapchat may get into this well
there's a belief in all of these tech
companies that you can present much more
information visually than you can with
words and that the Internet is basically
going to be images and not text in the
future that people engage much more
heavily with video than they do with
text so they are prioritizing it you can
see it like Facebook is putting the
camera front and center they're putting
the video tab front and center and
they're now trying to go into high
quality content
if they could be able to take the kinds
of skills I held in Hollywood in terms
of how you creativity could this mean
they replace television networks and
Hollywood Stewie's II now easy I think
that they're going to be wary about that
right so Facebook has always had this
tension right are we a publisher or are
we a platform do we create content or we
just a platform on which you put content
and they've always said no no no we're a
platform we're not a publisher no no not
at all
and now they're getting more and more
like a publisher but they're not going
to go full into it they're not going to
have giant sued example you talk to some
people in the cable business or in
Hollywood they worry about Facebook and
they worry about Apple because they've
got so much money they've got so much
money and they have massive ambitions
and they have so much data this is what
Facebook has that nobody else when they
are trying to figure out what show to
fund they know every single thing about
all the people and they know their moods
at any given moment so they can promote
the right show to them and as their
artificial intelligence algorithms get
better they will be pushing new shows
that you want when you want them and in
some ways Amazon has already shown the
way Amazon has shown the way and Netflix
has also shown the way using their data
to create shows Facebook is much more
data than any of them what about Mark
Zuckerberg future I mean he gave a very
good commencement address not only the
message but also his performance he's
clearly upped his game he's upped his
game and he's read a lot of political
speeches right now calling out people
the little anecdotes he's traveling
around the country he has definitely
upped his game with nice suit he's been
training very hard for this moment and
he's gotten much better at the
performance of it good speech and he
wore a suit he did it looked pretty good
and a tie okay the whole kit and
caboodle and he started with some nice
jokes he's got the form down he's more
comfortable congratulations to all the
graduates again Nick Thompson thank you
so much thank you